all right Peter thank you for the
introductions and let me just mention my
name is LAN Fatima practically 4db snip
and also this for this project so today
we'll be going over brief introduction
of alpha project for those that new to
the project and also we'll go over a
little bit about the recent data
released our first release and then
we'll go dive right into the tutorials
for an how to access the data then we'll
conclude with some question anyway I
would encourage you to visit the project
home page it contains a lot of details
about the project and also an addition
it contains previous webinars including
this alpha project introductions and
also a lot of the material that I won't
be covering today there will be a source
webinar such as the various service
that's relevant today's talk so this
project is to provide a good new
frequency from DB gap and all those you
provide frequency from over 1 million
subjects so we can use a seven
introduction to DB gap is a speedy gap
page this sort of the state that has
some is beta it has so DB gap is the
database of genotype and phenotype and
it stores studies over thousands of
studies from and the results that for
looking at the association between
genotype and phenotype and their effect
on course the Jesus answer and
everything else they also had thousands
of phenotype data sets and hundreds of
thousands of variables and millions of
subjects
and it also contains a lot of molecular
data set including all the genotyping
and so this shows you these are millions
of subjects and events you know type on
various platforms including microarrays
and direct sequencing from a whole exome
and whole genome so this project is to
provide
eget all the Heritage data from all the
different platforms and and then
homogenized and or monologist do and
report in a standard format and then it
will be integrated into please and then
be available first methods so the only
real TV snip this is officially a little
changes and the pipeline to use this
data okay so so just a brief summary of
the data flow so again we select approve
studying DB gap and go to the QC process
then we compute the I normalize the
subject and their ancestry and an
assignment your population all the data
from the various platform and standard
converter standard input VCF format do a
compilation of pipeline where we
normalize the very ends aggregate then
compute the frequency and then provide
the product I won't go into the detail
of how the variants are normalized get
to say that this has lesbian improvement
in terms of the RS assignment posturing
and reduce a lot of the issues that are
PD what else in Oakland is still where
we have bernstrom like RS assign
duplicate RSM for the San Baron and so
on like that this para normalization and
publish are tricky to read if you want
more detail to be endorsed on this off
the webinar from a year ago that's on
the project homepage okay so we had our
first release about a month ago and just
starting with just a modest four to four
to studies and that included about
hundred thousand subjects have a
chilling genotype and the output we get
is that says he cluster down to about
half a billion variants weak variants
and although most of those don't exist
in CV snip but we also found some novel
variants so this has compared even those
from the few studies how this compared
to adverse project at least before and
alpha that's comparable in terms of
scale and scope with other projects as
nomads and top nerd and the fact in
terms of the number of subjects and
variants so this is show their breakdown
in terms of populations from the initial
release but still bias or primarily
European but we do have some you know
significant numbers for the some of the
continental larger populations but a
future of plan is to improve our amino
to increase the number of these numbers
subject with the underrepresented
population but again there's about how
the previous release had of a hundred
thousand subjects but so this is just a
small fraction of the available subject
and DB gap for this almost two million
and we already analyzed some subjects
which has genotype and identified over
almost a year almost a mule and a half
subject that could be across all
candidates best input Duty alpha project
so look forward for more more data
coming we also look at comparing the
data from our projects with two other
projects see how they stack in terms of
concordance and quality and in terms of
the ancestry but also the Barents and
the populations so here what we're
looking at is we're comparing the Alpha
Theta of minor low frequency versus on
genome to the marthy went on you know
one new frequency it's plotted on the
x-axis alphas on the y-axis and for each
of the common population so if they both
agree in terms of for the same variant I
should just so aligned on this
by the angle and if you see our ancestry
for the populations and the Barons are
put in a consistent with the 1000 genome
and these new line indicate the outliers
limit so we said like put actively
string gender difference of plus and
minus 0.15 in even then you know we have
very few variants these are in and
informative markers that we used to
interrogate or to compare near the
comparison and there's very few outliers
and we also did the same thing with
nomads and top men - that's good
concluding between our data and these
other projects so so the second point is
that our data the alpha project is
consistent with other project and in
terms of quality and and concordance and
also the answer C - because if you look
in the different pairs they went down
you know and alpha the European
population test is very similar and that
we are pretty good in terms of assigning
the population groups
a look at other variant of interest as
the Barons in Clinton bar genetic
testing registry these mostly contain
the drug response marketers and also
varies in dbgap was Kellogg sent any
variant that has association p-value of
less than pension amount of five to some
particular traits a phenotype and then
we also look at the parents that paquimé
interested in in terms of those that
have been cited in publication lemonhead
description of phenotypes or other valid
biological facts of the variance as you
see here there even with that smaller
rods moment subject we started with you
have pretty good coverage for most of
the apparently these other resources and
if you want to get a subset of these
data its VCF format if we get it from
our FTP site and of supplement material
and so the Alpha frequency alpha
frequency data according to use of our
para stage the rest of the page it's in
the frequency tab I can see here we
report the total population or the total
project across off Sunny's frequency we
report the sample size the reference
allele of the low-frequency and also the
continent or sub population frequency
for instance European African Asian and
so on okay we also provide you
population frequency when there's
available for variance from over
hundreds of other project that that
would listen to these different found
genome exact no matter that you can
compare the data of the cross projects
now we've start diving into the
tutorials or the walkthrough in terms of
how do you actually find events
interesting it to the RS page or the
variant
so you can start that with searching DB
snip and we provide the document here
let's provide all the support a search
term but does include the RS numbers mr.
by RS numbers it's your CB zip by both
GRCC area seventy are secured a position
genius image and ID and also other
important actress at the frequency range
clinvar insignificant and many others so
we'll go here and take a look so this is
the help page for all the supported
search field and terms and DB snip so
and we provide you the few name aliases
some descriptions and some of the
possible good news word this on a sample
created here you mister grch38 position
grch37 position clinvar clinical
significance and so on and gene is
someone like that there are some sample
you down here too so I'll pause one here
one second not to mention that we will
be adding additional attributes
specifically for alpha projects we get
those so that will make you easier use a
search for variants that have alpha
project unfortunately to get it done for
this webinar but it should that should
be the next appeal release or next week
or so but because the system is so
robust I think we can get lucky and I
can soon push you with that
demonstration how to find a parent with
alpha Pacific frequency so we'll go back
to so here's the sample search we're
going to do today and let me just make
this fullscreen so we can look for a
clinvar bearing that has conflict
interpretation of pathogenicity where
perhaps maybe the frequency can inform
you or provide some insight about you
know what the effect of the variance is
we also want to find one where there's a
suicide and publication so that you can
find these text mining a little bit
search or read about a phenotype in a
biological effects and then we get those
mother acted you like that we want to
miss on variant and its cost about
validations
what this is it means that
there is defendant similitude DBC most
of all times the same tournament up
there but and by mortal submitters so
it's a chumpy of the lowest validation
and give you step between two useful the
very may be real and that observant
independently multiple times but we also
look for one day I have no frequency
part from any project so that hopefully
the only 15 with this path is from the
elf vodka so this is pretty complex
Korea even if you have to do this by
sequel or other mean it's still pretty
complex but I'll show you how neat it is
when this is doing to be snip so the
query that if you have to generate is
actually this and don't be scared by
this because I'm going to show you how
to do it using two methods using the
filter and advanced search and within
the address to their system that you can
can't just clear without even touching
the keyboard so what she with that now
so go ahead that period I just did
return following these four results
right
for variance so this is pretty complex
Pierre is not gonna have a lot of
bullying joining in public that so just
to show you how the school bus the
system is so how do you genders career
without even touching the keyboard so if
we just go to Oscar and book so if
you're starting new you can go these two
home pages of search box of course this
reminder there's a link to the alpha
project here then below that we have
some example of search terms and also
additional and link to the help page but
here you see this filter here that will
show you all the record that's a villain
TV snip so we're just go and pull that
up and then we'll use the filter to
drill down the data so see that's fairly
quick return no over half a billion
records in no time okay so here's the
sort I'm talking about when the left so
I gave you looking at so cool we'll go
ahead and check off the actually a
little Asian in again Glen barbarian
with collecting interpretation that's a
chicken this T so that do it down to a
few thousand let's take a little further
we'll go again we wanted to be cited and
publications their RSS and that because
it's I like the information about it and
we'll go ahead and click on this
sentence but especially changing them
that much but okay out of 248 and then
we'll want to valid by cluster
so that gets you down a 248 but if you
can see here these are still has
frequency data that's reported here as
one we have ever shown you of different
projects that has fruit low frequency
like I said mentioned earlier and the
next build will have one of these line
will include the Alpha frequency so very
now we go house is dead
okay so then packaging of the 248 once
the one option you could do is also they
also again use the pre over here and you
can edit this like I said we're going to
touch a new keyboard and then we'll go
to advanced so this is advanced search
Google page just to beat the search box
turns curious a builder and then there's
some search history down here look the
recent searches so there's our initial
search we had four and then this is as
we drill down from the filthiest stores
all the history to but so we're going to
include this in the query builder so
that put that in there but then we're
going to go yoga this here we're going
to select not and then exclude anything
the frequency data submitted by other
projects so above do it without fukushi
validation status so we're going short
the index and there's frequency and
that's it and now it's goodbye just
going to do is go search but include
anything which we can see day right so
going through the search and there it is
he's going to stop the only full record
you can see quickly is no longer report
for these other agreements right and
there's so little detail here you still
need the variant type and all that stuff
in position allele and of course it's
all the action will be selected in this
central quick thing that's just that's
just in the Missa tee and someone like
that are they by cluster in publication
so long so will tell about this one and
dis are as the first we go
see what this the frequency can review
or tell us about variants so we go here
this is the detailed DBC of our support
page again different details up here
some summary information public and then
over here we have some various tab or
the different data section clinic and
the frequency is here and then here's
the Alpha frequency data again this
shows you the privacy across off study
so there's sample size reference bill of
allele frequency and then the sub
population of course there's not no
frequency for some other project access
top method okay so this shows you that
the spirit of Lewis actually pretty
common across most common population
where we have data okay so he throw the
clinic significant and so what does that
tell us
and because the day all the days
integrated here in the rest of Asia to
try to get the all the data and to the
clinvar assertions clinical assertions
so here is the one that would be
conflicting interpretation accession
under our puts on that again so this
significant bar page and it shows you
about the very detail again comes in the
conditions and they down here you have
the clinical assertions submit about tip
is similar to an ole mangies view I mean
the evidence section you can see drill
down detail Warwick provided in terms of
how they asserted the clinical
significance so here's the old man will
click on that to look and you can see
here so here's this bearing is indeed
found in 40% of the patients but then
down here it is also is found in the 11
or 13 percent of deaf population which
consists in what alpha reported rate
this around in the team
and then just a general common variant
so anyway so that may provide you some
insight into you know okay what did that
mean and so on like that but also
important I want to get back to this
cage is that this time I do a beacon
essentially into DB gap because what
this tells you that this variant
existent DB gap they actually have
thousands of subjects that carry this
variant so you can actually go into DB
gap and get get after genotype if you
want to investigate further look about
appearance or interrogate the genotype
of those individuals and do more details
or or get the a phenotype of the
attributes that have been described and
Heba calf to see how this know that they
are associate that this bearing okay so
that is really the power of this
connection between the parent and the DB
gap theta right down here cell frequency
itself reported here alright so that was
that how you do for the web search
and then next we're moving to how do you
do this programmatically and we start do
using the EU till again we have a help
document here Pacific for DVF how to use
it util with DB snip data basically you
use the same query syntax so you can use
the web develop your career test agree
then you just basically just put it in
your codes and it's the same syntax and
that should work all you can use as a
basis is dynamically change the query
rate if you've got the sit-downs of
genes a thousand after each one look at
so we'll go ahead and do it as tutorials
and Jupiter notebook and we'll go look
at that now so DB tip has a github site
and we have a tutorial section of the
directory digit and within that there's
a bunch of different tools you can walk
through and go ahead look up this one
and bind there so well particularly
non-technological odor while slow to
explain what's going on here so we just
reload the standard python module file
python module and we'll import into
entre library or module and then we'll
use that to create DB snip using
research and in the end just using the
general same term used for the web and
then what okay great
almost done I'll go ahead and run it all
just forget to started in the image okay
so here that's loading movie so here
we're using the history so that we can
centi a key back that we can use to
manipulate the data or retrieve it in
batches and we want to and this just
very just finished return 20 records
doctor I ran it so we do the query you
create a set and create a handle or
through the research we do the query
then we get the results and then here's
some parameters that return some results
that going to help you so what's going
to do with it so then for this query
don't return 5 RS and this included here
in this idealistic parameter and then
this was a freaky that we'll use and
there's some Christians Latian so if
detail down here some case if you zoom
results back you may want a time did the
detail to see what what if it took your
crude correctly anyway so we'll get the
rest list will print out the rest
numbers now prepare and then we'll go
ahead and pass those three parameters
that we got back from a search into each
fetch and then here is download the XML
but you should those records so and then
that's that so we could just do how
going to copy this just show it to you
demonstration then we'll go ahead and
paste it in here
and run it get to dissolve that and then
so here before the penis cor 10:5 and
also it is from the Chester stage n4 so
nice thing about you noticing you can
interact and play with it and experiment
with it and then even edit the codes and
then once you're done you just go here
and go download us by coding you're done
you ready ready to use okay
so that was one of them that's a simple
example and now we'll walk through a
little more complicated example so in
addition to e util and on trip we also
have another circle the nclibraries to
service a TI so this reflects a Swiss
Army knife or a tool box you can imagine
because it also does like remapping it
does conversion between different
notation which is HTS BCF RS numbers our
own internal speedy conversion and
recently we just are supported year for
hbr here creation objects like I said
this has been covered in the webinar a
year ago and there's a link on the
bottom of the alpha project but page of
that webinar see is much I won't go into
detail about that but we did introduce
three new function Pacific for this
alpha project and that's to retrieve the
the metadata about the project on the
study and video and the sense of
population description and then there's
one to get the retrieve the all the
variants within a sequence interval so
and then also of course to get the
frequency by RS wanders and we'll walk
through some real examples now so we
have developed a bunch of tutorials a
stupid a notebook again including for
how to do it how to search by genes are
retrieved by RS numbers using VCFs an
input and so on so we'll go over there
you
okay
and in addition we have other tutorials
or notebook on how to use to do the
conversion between the notation that
subscribe the variations for service
support and there's also a module with
us there's a wrap around the allows
mixing the colloid object-oriented and
little cleaner joint use that that's a
wrap around the the API but here's our
the Alpha Pacific notebooks and there
are on binders so you can just launch
them from here if we have campus genes
are a intricacy and couple other ones
here and then then one for to are
searching for occurring for more direct
people mouth PP but we started with our
assignment system the simplest one okay
take a little second little again it's
just by us loading again still in
standard modules Python module so here's
the call to get the frequency of our s
number is just basically just you
substitute in RS number and that's it
and then they'll get the frequency okay
I'll go ahead and run at all
okay welcome see us and also in addition
to that what what this does is so here
it is so it go to return so we retrieve
as far as 16 so we return here's the
object our JSON object for that RS
numbers so include the build ID number
so if you maintain our local database
some you what you know you want to be
currently up-to-date you could compare
the built ID so it's just the data
clustering of the date that was the bill
who shot the bill the Alpha bill then
the result contained the chromosome
number and then position the RAF allele
and then about project IDs for this
alpha project then the real counts for
each of the population and the properly
described using our sample ID and then
the allele counts for each of those
population okay the next and then also
this received the metadata they just
want a single call no parameters which
we treat the metadata and out of
presenting discredit dictionaries and
other data showed that if you want
instead of showing that our sample and
you want to show more on common terms
you can do that they translate and then
this is just some housekeeping stuff but
a sense this is the call for RS number
with some error handling that you need
for when you're doing with the doing web
request ok so then it's down here in
this so I'll put it all together with
another data and then print it out down
here ok like I said before you can
pretty much interactive play with this
and then go ahead and put some more some
in here run it and then you get instant
results or you can tweet them fine-tune
this so how you want to go for your own
purpose okay I will get out of that know
when the next one is will go
so this one combined both so this is a
search by gene directly variation shift
API that not support gene search the
only support support search deposition
but you can get the gene position from
the gene database and then use that the
search the API so here we show you how
to do that by integrating both the EU
till API and the very service let me
just run Z
so you use essentially here is this
function up here get the gene location
decision util each summary and the
current gene database to get the gene
information for the gene ID and then it
just parts the locations out and then
use that location to then search this
query the gradient source API to get the
variance within that region and then
again we just wrap all this up in terms
of there's some error handling and
but because so here I'm using that range
we query for actually I think I scored
GP 53 yeah 50 53 so we got the range
from gene database and then we create
the database so we get over our 1,300
variants and like I said before this to
show you the query that I could use to
get the variance there's a limit of for
each query for 250 variants and this
shop we can look at them they here again
it's just return efficient object so you
can parse out into into the more from
the format and like I said we have your
mostest codes up here just to do the
iterative and handling of the request so
that's so this is kind of nice and that
I show you how to integrate book is
utils and version API and then I think
this will buy more flexibility and that
really can search for any genomic
features less really enhance your
promoters or getting other variants
using positions so there's other thing I
want to mention is that when you create
the various API not only just be getting
back the existing RS variant you also
gain from novel parents that's been
discovered by alpha the web searches and
the of course there won't be no RS page
for it but if you want the latest
greatest data the API and the FTP
download this ways you can get both with
the existing and novel variants I'll
just go
you
you
all right so we went through numbers
search bar if you go by RS by gene we're
almost out of time so I won't go into
this with you may want look at this one
this is also it that's me mapping is
taking input of G su-37 VCF be map DG is
38 queries a day at the API and we'll go
quickly go into this one quick this
Google I have ones because this to the
curry to the FTP VCF so the reason you
want to use this is if you have a
firewall person you want to correct you
use the FTP download or whatever reasons
limitation through the web request you
can use but this I could create our the
Alpha FTP DCF like I mentioned for a
contain both existing RS variants and
also T now abeyance quickly just using
inputting
the standard Tabak Python module here we
have some handling for the large request
just housekeeping stuff and then it just
created a ftp site to get the arrange on
chromosome 1 at this position return to
earth data and it just had a VCF format
is a brief header and then the standard
positions RS idea that if it's available
this novel you won't have an RFID and
then all and then run all Kaleo and then
each of the population at thousand by
being and then W counts and then there's
a bunch of other housekeeping function
there and then there's also a the meta
data and if you want is you on a map
that say the boss sample city and that's
before in the standard common terms and
then spread out the go down here and
then like I said before you can tweak
around the play around with the range of
whatever then they'll just iterate
through and just keep calling the data
okay so that's pretty much conclude the
so webinar for today in terms of the
tutorial and so I want to conclude Shane
that's this is a growing data set as I
mentioned for with probably at less than
percent of what the Bill and DC gap so
look forward to in avalanche of data
come in the future
and we'll be updating this regularly
we'll try to get quarterly update and
cover news novel being and update as you
could see data and the other key thing
is that we Center taken did all the
heavy lifting take all the heaviness
data normalizing and most in terms of
variant the subjects population and the
exchange format put to easy use and the
key point again is that this provide a
beacon identity gap and the way you can
actually do our backside to apply and
get the individual genotype and their
phenotypes and so on like that for
further interrogation so with that I'll
hand it back over to Peter and then
follow-up or questioning thanks line we
actually have a lot of questions and I
don't think we're gonna have time to get
to all of them you know it's sort of get
to some general themes one thing they
came up a couple of times is the
aggregate data from TV gap those include
you know they include studies that
include cancer patients is that not true
yes there could be some patients in
there the nice thing with you the gap is
all that attributes this have been
captured so presumably in the future we
could slice and dice data however so if
you look at the possibility in terms of
number of attributes in these
measurements and so the deflation basis
by cases there's a control age sex
different cohorts whatever how you want
it so the posses endless so that is
really the power but where we started
with just general yes we'll discover
pathogenic parents also to be able these
wouldn't be somatic variants were they
in the way these data are generated well
it's hard because somatic variant calls
are typically hard to identify the being
with there may be that no pass some
filtering mechanism depending on how the
study was so there
I say we have done some analysis and
we'll share that later but we do compare
some of the variants with in terms of
with other somatic databases to see
where there may be possible somatic
variant candidates we did look at that
cosmic I think a few other cancer sites
but yeah so there could be some but but
again frequency may inform you right
they don't deserve in one or two person
out of a hundred thousand or million
papillote somatic or very supremely rare
mutation or refugees whatever they okay
related to that it I think you alluded
to this manatee will there be a way
later on to sort of get subsets of these
it wouldn't include for example cancer
patients oh yeah wait now we accept this
is our mission lesion would be greater
we and this resource is something give
up all users and direction that we can
take it will depend on what we get that
feedback will get some use so we would
like people to use this data also drill
down to a software whether user was not
and the more feedback we get from users
the more help us to prioritize in terms
of what we want to take it we're going
to take it rips immune it's a way we get
slice of Isis data so we encourage users
to use it please provide feedback you
know what you like to see what you don't
like oh and any issues and I think it's
overall helped improve for everybody
else so we really need user feedback and
comments so you can always send down
this last slide just let me comment on
that there are some places where you can
go these URLs are on the slide where you
can find out you know more about NCBI
services and so forth but just if you
want it you know provide feedback write
to us at the NCBI help desk info and I'm
afraid we're kind of out of time
but there are a lot of questions in
there that we haven't addressed fully
but I will make sure that we get them
answered and I'll put that up on the FTP
site and you'll get an email from an
automatic email from the good webinar
program actually but it will have a link
to that site and we'll get the Q&A
document and there
we'll have the answers to the other
questions that people asked and there
were a lot of good ones today thanks
everybody for coming and thanks LAN and
I'm going to go ahead and in the webinar